- I'm so bad at this.
(exciting music)
- So the options are Jack
in the Box, Burger King,
Wendy's, McDonald's,
Chick-fil-A, and In-N-Out.
- I eat fast food,
unfortunately all the time.
- I love fast food.
It definitely did get me through college.
- I eat fast food sporadically.
- I'm not like a fast food connoisseur.
- I think I'll be pretty decent at it.
But there are a lot of options here.
- When I was younger I never thought
fast food was gonna ever
actually make me feel sick.
Now it does.
- Let's see, number one.
We have, oh yeah.
This is a larger sized bun.
- It smells like wheat beer.
- So this bun, oh actually...
- This looks like a Big Mac bun.
But it's maybe a little too big for it?
- If it was a Big Mac
there would be a third bun.
Unless you're tricking me.
- It's weird eating the bread
without the actual sandwich.
- I think this is a Whopper.
(ding)
- It smells like Burger King.
It looks like Burger King.
So I have to say Burger King.
Burger King.
- So the sesame seeds are
definitely a give away.
This is a Whopper from Burger King.
(ding)
- It's either McDonald's or Burger King.
McDonald's.
(buzzer)
- I'm gonna say this is Burger King bun.
(ding)
- I think sesame seeds is a McDonald's,
it's indicative of...
I'm gonna say McDonald's.
(buzzer)
Or it could be Burger King.
(ding)
But McDonald's here.
(buzzer)
- Oh, okay.
I don't think I recognize it.
- Look at that.
That's a simple bun.
- Oh, this could be McDonald's too.
They have two kinds of bread.
It tastes very plain.
It tastes almost perfect.
- Yeah, it's definitely really dry.
- It's toasted, so that's good.
This is more the size I would expect
from like McDonald's
(buzzer) or something.
- McDonald's.
(buzzer)
This is McDonald's for sure.
- I know I know this bun.
So that's a Chick-fil-A bun.
(ding)
- It's In-N-Out.
(buzzer)
- I'm gonna go with McDonald's
(buzzer) on this one.
- Certainly not Chick-fil-A.
That's gonna be the easiest one.
I think.
Well, no this could be Chick-fil-A.
Fuck.
I'm gonna say this is
Chick-fil-A (ding) for now.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
Burger King has the stuff on it.
This is Burger King (ding),
this is McDonald's (buzzer).
Wait, yeah, yeah.
- I'm surprisingly good at this I think.
- Ah shit, that's the identical bun.
This is harder than I
thought it was gonna be.
- Ah man, see now I think I'm wrong.
- Oh wow.
This bun is burnt.
It is crunchy.
- I would eat this as
toast in the morning.
- Smells like a blanket.
- I'm gonna guess Jack in the Box.
(buzzer)
- That's a good quality bun.
I'm gonna say this is In-N-Out.
(ding)
- I'm gonna go with Chick-fil-A
(buzzer) on this one.
- Uh, Wendy's.
(buzzer)
- It smells like Wonder bread.
Jack in the Box?
(buzzer)
- Chick-fil-A.
Oh my God, I'm so good at this.
There's no IN-N-Out here, right?
- [Man] Yes there is.
- This is IN-N-Out.
(ding)
- Oh man, these are really tough.
- It's oily.
- I don't recognize the
shiny top of the bun.
- This feels artisanal.
I just like that word, artisanal.
- This one actually tastes
a little bit better.
- I think since they're
on that new health kick,
this is probably a new McDonald's bun.
(buzzer)
Yep, definitely tastes like McDonald's.
- This feels like, like
fancy, like Chick-fil-A.
(buzzer)
This feels like Wendy's (buzzer) actually.
- Is this In-N-Out?
(buzzer)
I'm gonna guess this one's In-N-Out.
- So I'm gonna say this is Wendy's.
(buzzer)
- I'm getting In-N-Out vibes.
I say In-N-Out.
- I think that glisten
is from Jack in the Box.
(ding)
- This is so much fun.
- Wow.
- Oh (bleep) off.
Are you kidding me?
- Holy crap.
They all look the same.
- I'm losing my confidence
as I work my way to the end.
- It also feels nice putting
bread against your face.
- That a Wendy's bun.
(buzzer)
I eat Wendy's way too much.
Cause I just opened it, I'm like
"Oh yeah, this is Wendy's".
Definitely.
- Actually can I change my mind?
That's Chick-fil-A, (buzzer) Chick-fil-A.
Wendy's.
(buzzer)
- This is McDonald's.
(ding)
I can see a double
cheeseburger can be on that.
- I just had In-N-Out this weekend.
This is In-N-Out.
(buzzer)
- I think I already guessed McDonald's.
But know I'm thinking I should have
saved McDonald's for later.
I'm gonna go with Jack in the Box.
(buzzer)
- I'm gonna say this is Jack in the Box.
Disturbingly similar to McDonald's.
So I could be wrong here.
- Oh this one looks so good.
- You made me think that they were all
gonna be different cause of that one.
- Oh this smells like
so real and authentic.
Oh my God.
- It's soft.
It's lightly toasted, not
too rough like that one.
- By process of elimination
then this must be Wendy's.
(ding)
I really don't know.
- I mean I guess In-N-Out's
(buzzer) the last option.
I really lost track.
This is the one that I
feel least familiar with.
I eat Wendy's way too much.
Cause I just opened it, I'm like
"Oh yeah, this is Wendy's".
Definitely.
This is In-N-Out.
I'm right.
I feel so confident.
- I'm gonna say this is Chick-fil-A.
(buzzer)
I loose my confidence here, there.
- In-N-Out. (buzzer)
- So this is Wendy's, Wendy's left?
That's not Wendy's.
- This is In-N-Out.
(buzzer)
This is Chick-fil-A.
- It makes me think of how
much we take bread for granted
when you're eating a burger or a sandwich.
Because it's like you don't care.
It's all about the meat.
- Out of six, I think I
got one, maybe two right.
- I feel like I'm changing my mind.
- [Man] Okay, so that's Burger King.
- This is Burger King?
(ding)
- [Man] ...and Chick-fil-A.
- Seriously?
Wow, this is crazy because I never thought
I would confuse McDonald's
with Chick-fil-A.
- Wow.
I feel so bad for getting Wendy's wrong.
I mean McDonald's comfort me too,
but like McDonald's is
like my side chick, so.
- Oh what?
Wendy's was so good.
I don't eat at Wendy's.
Maybe I should.
- This was probably the
hardest thing I've ever done.
- Final (bleep) verdict.
This is still Burger King.
(ding)
I'm saying this is Burger King.
Mcdonald's.
(buzzer)
Chick-fil-A.
Jack in the Box.
(ding)
what's left, Wendy's and In-N-Out?
- [Man] Yes.
- Wendy's (buzzer), In-N-Out (buzzer).
- [Man] If you had not
changed your answers
you would have been 100% correct.
- Really?
That's Wendy's?
(bleep) me.
(electronic music)